hi everyone salicon here welcome to our
homeroom live stream today we have a
disappointing guest it is me
we'll be doing it ask me anything uh so
feel free to start putting your
questions in the message boards down
below or wherever they are on the side
on facebook
or on youtube and we'll try to get to as
many of those questions as possible but
before i begin i'll give my standard
announcements first of all a reminder
that khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist through
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about making a
donation at khan academy.org
donate i also give a special shout out
to several organizations that have
stepped up when they found out that we
were having
a deficit even before covid and then
with kovan you could imagine traffic on
khan academy has grown up grown
dramatically so special thanks to bank
for america google.org att fastly
novartis and the many other folks who
have helped fund khan academy and you
know i had given uh we had a guest
several two weeks ago talking about how
to be a happier person one of the best
ways to be a happy person is to give
to others or to give to missions that
might help others so
i believe all of these organizations are
now going to be happier organizations
because of the work that they know
they're doing for others and all of you
all who are donating hopefully feel the
same
extra announcement reminder about
homeroom with sal the podcast it's
essentially what you're getting right
now but in podcast version safe to drive
while you are consuming it
so with that i'm eager to to answer any
questions that you have about anything
and so let's see it looks like we
already have a few from last time
and we're going to add more let's see
aaron brandt says
how do your kids feel about math
um
i so my i have a 11 year old a 9 year
old and a 6 year old
my 11 year old is really into math uh
very much into math so you know if you
if you give them a interesting math
problem et cetera et cetera wants to
tackle it like really curious about it
my nine and six year olds i think they
are well on their way uh but they are
still in the kind of early phases of
their math uh progression but you could
imagine this is one area where it would
be i feel it would be a shame if if my
children did not grow up
knowing the beauty of actually all of
learning uh but especially math and
actually all of the learning i i want
them to see wonder wherever they go in
the world and realize that in all of
this wonder we can start to understand
it through
math through science through the
humanities
so i'm i'm working on it
let's see next question
uh from christopher mcnaid on facebook
are there any specific news subjects
that you want to include
in khan academy
sorry i just had a keto popsicle that's
like a anyway that's a whole other
conversation if y'all want me to talk
more about that uh but
it's going down a little bit still uh
other subjects to add on khan academy so
you know we've talked about math and we
already have you know pre-k with khan
academy kids k first grade and second
grade now we're adding khan academy ma
on khan academy kids and that also has
reading writing and social emotional
learning at those same grade levels and
in the math we go all the way in fact
we've just launched mult all the way
through calculus statistics and now
multi-variable calculus we've always had
videos but now we have exercises as well
so i hope to keep adding uh and and
building out our math science a lot of
you all know we already have a lot of
science content but over the course of
the next year expect to see
even more science content by next back
to school i'm hoping that we have
significant chunks or if not all of the
major things you need in middle school
and high school across all of the
sciences and then over time you know we
already have some english and language
arts and history content and other
humanities content i hope that we can
add a lot more over time but you know it
goes back to my fundraising ask at the
beginning uh you know we're we're
limited by the resources we have on not
just the ability to create the content
but also to make sure that our platform
our software the practice works really
well and is really important the teacher
tools work well for the kind of content
we are trying to
address so let's see
uh the
see there's a question here
incorporating art for khan academy i
don't think we're going to be doing any
like deep dive and like teaching the
arts
but we do have art history on khan
academy done by beth and steven who are
close partners of khan academy smart
history all that content is available on
khan academy so i encourage you to look
into that
so let's see from facebook snehanath
do you think standardized testing will
always be here or do you think something
else will replace them
well you know
sometimes you know standardized testing
a lot of people
you know say oh well that gives you know
it creates stress and all of these types
of things but i always remind folks
that
you know
the opposite of standardized testing is
non-standardized testing or not testing
at all and if if you're not measuring
something it's very hard to know whether
you know it or whether you're growing or
how well you know it
and if it's done in a non-standardized
way
well that's not much better because
how do you understand where you are
compared to where you need to be in a
standardized way so i would say that you
know generally speaking in the world you
do need standardized measurement
and standardized testing is that is a
form of standardized measurement that we
use in academics
now i do think over time standardized
testing is going to be expanded or it's
going to evolve i think the types of
standardized testing that we're familiar
with i think you'll always have
standardized tests that'll be you know
how well can you factor a polynomial how
well uh how how strong is your reading
comprehension but i think then those are
going to be expanded with new forms of
standardized assessment uh where you
know maybe there's some type of
how well can you teach a subject how
well can you um
[Music]
you know compose a poem or something
like this and that you know having
interesting ways for maybe the community
to help evaluate you in a standardized
way
so
i don't think the notion of standardized
measurement or standardized tests are
are going away nor should they go away
but i think over time they will evolve
and will have a kind of a broader
aperture of what and how they can
measure things
so let's see from facebook rahm says why
do you use your name why don't you use
your name is salman instead of sal
so salman is my my full first name my
full name is salman khan so the reason
why i go by sal
you know it's really what my mother has
called me from the beginning so this
you know a lot of times
folks especially folks who have a name
that is not familiar to folks where they
live they'll sometimes shorten their
names and you know definitely a lot of
folks in my family have done that my
mother's name is masuda
and uh for convenience purposes i i was
probably around 12 or 13 years when she
decided to tell people who are not
familiar with the name masuda that her
name was sue
uh you know i have a
i have an uncle azad he goes by zach i
have an uncle makbool he goes by mac
i have an uncle khalid who actually goes
by jason which is completely unrelated
he was uh he worked on a ship for a
while and he was always fascinated by
jason the famous sailor had a have an
uncle ershad who goes by daniel once
again not an obvious shortening of the
name
uh
he liked that song you know
is traveling tonight on a plane anyway
long story short that's not the cause of
my name going from salman to saul to sal
it really is that my mom i think just
found it confu convenient to call me sal
when i was growing up
and then it did just happen to kind of
stick in my head um but i respond to
either sal or or salman what whatever
works for folks
let's see
other questions here
from let's see i answered that one
so from youtube joshua cataville said
how do you think artificial intelligence
will either help or damage the current
world of technology
that's a big question i don't claim to
be you know the world's leading expert
on artificial intelligence but i do like
to traffic in futurist ideas
um
i i mean i first of all i think the
genie is out of the box artificial
intelligence is going to be increasingly
used i think one of the hard things
about artificial intelligence is
it can create
you know positive optimizations for a
lot of things but sometimes you don't
know
why it's choosing one thing or another
and so i think artificial intelligence
can have many many very very positive
uses you know a lot of mundane human
tasks will not have to be done in a
mundane way by human beings
you'll have i could imagine artificial
intelligences that can help
improve your motivation that can help
you learn you know hope one day khan
academy can incorporate things like that
that can improve your relationship with
someone else you know that it asks the
right questions so it builds bonds
between you and another human being you
know yesterday we talked a lot with the
former surgeon general about kind of a
loneliness epidemic and you know it
seems a little dystopian
if your your loneliness is partly
addressed with an artificial
intelligence but there is you know maybe
something powerful about
you know sometimes being able to confide
in something that you know is it isn't
going to it where your your secrets are
are safe so i don't know there could be
some positive use cases but then there
could be a lot of weird new use cases
too i mean that last one i gave where
people
best friends end up becoming not a real
human being or artificial intelligence
is
you know there's several examples of
them developing their own biases based
on the data i mean in fact a lot of
machine learning is is all about kind of
forming a bias um
but some of those biases can be very
very unhealthy and you don't and it
might be expressing in very subtle ways
so yeah i think it's going to be very
it's going to be a brave new world the
next 10 or 20 years is uh you know we
really grapple uh with how artificial
intelligence is used or not um but but
it's gonna it's gonna be interesting
so from facebook my name is patrice and
i will be 60 years old next year would
it be possible for me to study
mathematics ab initio using khan academy
and work my way to a first degree ba or
bs in mathematics can khan academy give
me a good foundation so patrice first of
all i love that goal i think you're
fully capable of doing it my advice to
you would be
start on khan academy at the basics at
like you know you could probably
you could prob whatever whatever level
you think is is is kind of a little bit
easier than where you are and it could
be as early as if you haven't even done
you know basic arithmetic for many many
years go just go back to the beginning
go to kindergarten math on khan academy
or maybe second or third grade math on
khan academy start from the beginning
and master everything i think if you put
you know you'll get you'll get through
those first three things very quickly uh
those first many grade levels i think if
you're like a lot of adults uh probably
around you know some of the more
advanced arithmetic with decimals and
maybe some exponents and negative
numbers that's when you're going to
start needing some significant
refreshers that's going to be in 5th 6th
7th grade math and then a lot of adults
i think need need help refreshing in the
algebra but if you did that i would say
for 30 to 40 minutes a day say five days
a week
i think you're going to first of all be
at your learning edge in about a week or
two so you'll probably be at some of
that that early algebra stuff and then
you keep going master algebra master
geometry
algebra 2
master trigonometry precalculus calculus
statistics and if you want to be a math
major i would say then go on into
multi-variable calculus now you can do
all of that on khan academy now that's
going to take you some time depending on
where you are i think that might take
at least
a probably a year or so depending on
where you are on your journey but we've
had i've gotten letters from people in
your boat who've done it in about that
time frame maybe it might take a little
bit longer
and if you did that you would have an
excellent foundation for becoming a math
major in college uh on top of that we
have videos on differential equations
and linear algebra we don't have
exercises on those yet but i encourage
you to watch those pause the video try
to work through it yourself before i
work through it and so because if you
have a good foundation in algebra in
calculus
in uh and especially more advanced
calculus and linear algebra i i don't
think the math degree will be a problem
but you know it's it'll it will be a
journey i would predict if you do this
diligently you'll be ready to enroll at
a local university
in about a year or two and then you
you'd be off to the races on on your
degree
so late let's see next
next question
um
from youtube michael walker asked how do
you stay motivated sal khan i mean
sometimes it's hard to see the big
picture when you're an undergraduate and
graduate student what did you do to keep
on track
um
you know the thing that i remind myself
is that life is short and i you know i
maybe i was an old soul even when i was
in high school or when i was in college
but i always felt that life is short and
you know the last thing
that that i wanted to do is to kind of
you know make not make good use of you
know whatever precious moments i had on
this planet and so for me you know i i
like everyone i have those days where
things are not not going my way
um
and i'm not you know let's call it i
don't have the best self-esteem
sometimes
uh but i just remind myself that that
you know i as much as i can i try to
coach myself to say well you know that's
not going to help me
so let me let me do some small steps
that might get me out of my funk and
i've talked about this before you know
i've made my bed religiously now for
about 20 something years because that's
one small step you're like hey at least
i made my bed and then you know every
morning i try to do some push-ups i try
to do some pull-ups a new thing i've
started over the last two three years as
i take cold showers all of these things
have a way i meditate every day 30
minutes
and all of these things
they do they do two things for me they
give me wins no matter what the day is
going like no matter what headwinds i'm
facing or how i'm feeling about myself
or the world i'm like i made my bed i
got in there i took that cold shower
which is like a reboot of your brain i
meditated which is also like another
type of reboot of your brain it kind of
just you know opens it up you you start
to really still your mind all those
whatever negative thoughts they become a
lot less
than they were and you start you know
some positive thoughts start to slowly
slowly come out at least i find that
when i meditate um
and then you do some exercise gets your
blood flowing and it makes you feel
accomplished and then you know if you
can do the if you do that set of things
at least for me that set of things you
know if i can do that in the first hour
or two of my of my day
that i'm like this is going to be a good
day and you know sometimes it is
sometimes it isn't but i gotta say
especially the meditation even when
something happens at work and you know
it's disappointing or something in the
family and i'm like ah this is gonna be
so hard when you when you when the
meditation helps you from getting overly
attached to whatever that scenario is or
even overly attached to your own ego or
or your own fears
and when you're not overly attached to
those things then they don't feel as
heavy at least that's what i feel uh for
myself uh so you know if i had to pick
out of all of those habits i i would
probably pick making the bed and
meditating if i had to do only two
things and meditating start five minutes
and literally there's nothing mysterious
about it you just sit you know i try to
sit upright in a chair
hands on my lap and you know kind of
close my eyes
take some deep breaths in
and out
in fact do that right now just take some
deep breaths in
and out
and then i just start you know focusing
on my breaths and
i try to steal my mind as much as as
possible actually i was i was going
there just now so so but anyway that's
what i do maybe maybe one day we'll do a
meditation over over this this live
stream but i encourage you to you know
you just even those deep breaths you're
taking the deepest breaths of your of
your week or your month in
and out
you'd be surprised what that does for
you and there's some good biology behind
it it activates your parasympathetic
system which is the opposite of your
sympathetic system which is your
fight-or-flight response so it it forces
your body uh to relax and then if you
still your mind then everything all of a
sudden feels a lot less heavy
let's see
youtube jason souhay says sal i have
learned many subjects in my young life
and have trouble retaining that
knowledge over time how do you retain
the vast amount of information that
you've procured over the years
so i would say there's
two or three ways to really retain
knowledge
one is is while you're learning it try
to make as many connections as you can
say okay yeah that's what i do for the
test but let me draw some more
connections let me derive that formula
okay this formula in physics class says
this but i think i saw something very
similar in my calculus class or hey
they're talking about entropy and
computer science and they're also
talking about entropy in
chemistry how are these things related
and the more that you ponder these
things the more that those connections
will be there the second thing i'd
recommend is
uh just
applying them and you know the best way
to apply a lot of these skills is
actually to teach it to other people so
if you teach if you make a habit of
after you take a course the students who
take it the next year you want to teach
that course
trust me not only you're going to learn
it much much deeper but you're going to
retain that information much much better
some of you all know i have the side
project schoolhouse.world separate
effort from khan academy but it is a
place where you can do that where if you
need tutoring you can get free tutoring
but if you want to go deeper in your
subject matter
you can go tutor and actually had an
announcement with university of chicago
recently that they are going to be
looking at students who are really good
tutors of a subject
because they see if you can tutor the
subject not only do you know the subject
but that means you have great
communication you have empathy and
frankly you're probably going to retain
that subject and i think you're going to
see more and more of that in the future
so i highly recommend you to
start tutoring the subject yourself and
using it and then the third thing is you
know if you can if you can keep
revisiting the subject either because
you're tutoring it or because you know
you just continue to stay curious uh
that will also reinforce it so the the
ideas stay in your head
so let's see
from
youtube fateh sidesal says your english
is very fluent
what tips do you recommend to improve my
english well i can't take too much
credit for my english being fluent
because i was born in in the us in
metairie louisiana and actually many
people are surprised that i have what
they perceive as a very neutral american
accent despite the fact that i grew up
in southeast louisiana but people don't
realize that metairie louisiana
has kind of a neutral-ish accent
although there's a little bit of a it's
called a yat accent that you you kind of
hear there you'll hear my y'all every
now and then but that's why i have very
fluid english so i can't take much
credit for that
other languages that i kind of know
my bengali and my hindi slash urdu
my
is not very fluent it is
that was my bengali so anyway i just
told you know that it's always a journey
when you're not looking at your native
language um actually those are my my my
lang my languages where my my family
grew up but those aren't the ones that i
grew up but my advice for you if you
know
my theory and i'm not a linguistics
expert
is try to find people you can have
conversations with and the beauty of the
internet now is you don't have to
necessarily travel to meet people who
are fluent who are native speakers in
whatever language you want so i would
recommend if you want to become fluent
in english i've got to believe in fact
i'm 100 sure there's places on the
internet where you can practice your
english with native english speakers
and i think if you do a lot of that not
only will your english improve but
you'll probably meet some interesting
folks and they'll have a chance to meet
you
so let's see from youtube andrew briggs
says do you have anything about religion
on khan academy we actually have a good
bit about religion on khan academy from
a historical cultural lens
especially if you look at our world
history content we have a lot on
kind of the eastern traditions on
hinduism on buddhism
we have a lot on what i would say you
know the more i guess you say western
religions uh i guess mid mid mid eastern
religions
you know so we have a lot we have a
reasonable bit on the core of judaism
you know at least understanding the
narrative of the old testament we have a
good bit about um the at least the
gospels the kind of the life of jesus
and how
christianity evolved from the time of
jesus under the roman empire
all the way through constantine when the
roman empire you know they transitioned
from persecuting christians to becoming
the you know the the kind of the seat of
of christianity and we talk about uh we
have a good about four or five videos on
islam where you can understand you know
the historical underpinnings of it how
it started and how it grew uh
historically so that's what we have
right now i hope one day you know we we
get a chance to go deeper in all of
these because regardless of whether you
follow any of these religions or you
don't whether you are religious whether
you're atheist whatever your belief
system is uh
it's really valuable to understand
uh these religions which are you know
form the base of so much of our thought
and our culture so i highly recommend
you know taking a look at those things
on khan academy if you're not familiar
with any of them
so let's see other
questions
let's see i'm scrolling
there's a question here
from youtube mr specter asks is your job
stressful how do you make all these
educational videos how do you manage to
make this non-profit organization bloom
so it's a good question mr spectre i'll
tell you there are times that it is
stressful i'll tell you the video making
is not usually my source of stress
sometimes it's a little frustrating
because you know i keep bumbling over
myself or i really want to make sure i
understand something really really well
so i can get a little bit compulsive
about that but for the most part i find
the the video creation side to be almost
the relaxing side of my job it allows me
to kind of that's when i get into my
flow when i get into my zen i think the
stuff that gets stressful and you know
is
there there's a lot of folks who are
dependent on khan academy there's you
know that we have over 200 employees
there's thousands of volunteers around
the world
we have hundreds of thousands of donors
we have
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of users
and so
yeah when when people are dependent on
it you you don't want to um disappoint
folks and you can imagine
you know
raising money if i don't raise enough
money then we're not going to have the
resources to serve tens of millions of
folks so we're not able to hire folks or
you know even in you know in the past
we've even had to
downsize some at khan academy which is
an incredibly painful thing
um so those types of things develop a
lot of stress um i would say there's
there's times also when you know you
have passionate people who are trying to
do the right thing
you know the the root of passion is
worth suffering when you really care
about something you know we have we can
have heated debates within khan academy
of you know with the scarce resources we
have what is the best way to deploy that
or what is the best way to execute on
that uh and so you know i i often do
think about you know am i supporting our
team properly are we aligned are we
working on the right things you know are
the funders satisfied you know am i
communicating with them enough
so yeah these
these can sometimes make you wake up in
the middle of the night but that's why
i meditate and take cold showers and do
my push-ups and pull-ups and make my bed
and i make videos too that that all and
i don't want to make it sound like my
whole you know my job is like you know
some super stressful thing
it comes and goes you know there's
moments of of real
joy in fact it's it's mostly that uh but
yeah there are definitely moments of of
of stress uh and that and that's and
that's how i and that's how how i how i
deal with it i will say one thing you
know i remember
when i used to read i don't know i would
read like i would watch like movies and
there'd be like someone who runs a
company and they'd always be like oh
it's so lonely at the top and i'll be
like yeah it seems like it would be so
awesome to be the boss because then you
get to you know whatever you're the boss
how awesome is i have to say and not to
feel sorry i mean because i i feel very
privileged and lucky to have the role
that i have but yeah sometimes sometimes
the stress is because you know you
really can't tell other folks everything
that's going on in your head um and so
you have to figure out ways to to
resolve your own head uh sometimes but
yeah that that those are those are those
are all the stresses
see other questions here so someone's uh
so ayush is asking for the photo
explanation of the photoelectric effect
i'm tempted
but we have videos on that on khan
academy so i encourage you to to go
there and if that's not satisfying let
us know and we'll i'll make another
video to to answer any other questions
you might have
let's see from facebook victoria angelo
umedo says i'm working on getting a ged
but i get overwhelmed worried and
stressed any advice thank you
well my advice is you know if anyone's
getting overwhelmed or stressed about
anything
one you you can't underestimate the
power uh or you can't overestimate the
power of meditation
even five ten minutes a day once again
this is nothing mystical it's just you
being able to observe your thoughts
recognize that you are not your thoughts
you are not those negative feelings that
you are
you know those feelings are real they're
happening inside your brain but you are
something more than that and the you
know when you start to observe your mind
starts to still and you do literally
feel kind of a space form and you can
see okay there's this thought that's
saying oh i'm not going to be able to
achieve my goal or what are people going
to think of me and all of that but
you're like well that's just a thought
that's not me and then slowly that kind
of can die down and that i find once i
get to that point i'm just like you know
what regardless of the outcome let me
just do what's the right next step and
if i just do the right next step
i'll make progress hopefully and the
chips fall where they do you know
yesterday our guest uh vivek he talked
about the former surgeon general talked
about are we acting with ho are we
acting with love or are we acting with
fear
and i think you know these feelings of
procrastination feeling overwhelmed
these are feelings of fear you're like
oh well what if i do this and it doesn't
work out and
you know people are gonna think this
about me and that's going to happen i'm
not going to get that opportunity
instead i would say try to act out of
love or hope or however you want to
describe it we say well you know what
i'm just going to do the right thing at
any step of the way put one foot in
front of the other try to make progress
be a little bit further along today than
i was yesterday a little bit further
along in the next hour than i was in the
previous hour and that you're going to
notice that you're you're making
progress and it's like climbing a big
mountain you just put one foot in front
of the other and you know before you
know it you look back and you've you've
actually made a lot of progress so
that'd be my my meta advice i would say
just make a habit of doing the practice
when you get things wrong
don't beat up yourself remind yourself
that's actually moments of growth
reflect on why you got it wrong and keep
going you know i i'm a amateur guitarist
and you know there are these guitar
chords
that you know i've never been
a fan of uh but lately i've been like
you know what i need to just keep
practicing them every day and it is
amazing that your your brain slowly just
these things that felt impossible for
you uh after a week or two all of a
sudden feel very natural and very
automatic so i would just say keep at it
keep a habit of it
and uh you know and and always keep
perspective
let's see oh we're all out of time this
goes this goes by very very very fast um
so i will leave y'all there i'll give
i'll give one final announcement next
week i'm sure many people if you're 18
or over have already voted through your
mail-in ballots but remember on tuesday
it's election day so definitely vote uh
we're only going to have one live stream
next week on wednesday we're going to
have former secretary of education
margaret spellings and i think there's
going to be a very similar conversation
to what we had a conversation with arne
duncan last week but really just about
you know what's going on in education
and and how we can best navigate the
kind of the education crisis due to
covid uh together so look forward to
seeing all of y'all next wednesday at 12
pacific 3 eastern see you then
you